unaware to call Istanbul the heart of
turkey the pale area would be the cities
not many in the city or originally from
Istanbul as a hub of domestic migration
it's a Melting Pot of ethnicities
just days before turkey is most
important presidential and general
elections Johnson and her team are out
on the streets of baolu to campaign for
the governing God party and president
rejects will witness the conquest of
Istanbul once again Istanbul and Balu
are very important for president erdogan
he was born here in qasim Pasha of
course we will support him Istanbul
generates 30 percent of the national
income and nearly 50 percent of the
national tax revenue it also employs 24
percent of the country's labor
in Turkey Governors are appointed but
Mayors are elected that's why
municipalities like Istanbul with huge
financial resources are critical for all
political parties enormous amounts of
politically motivated rent has been
generated from Istanbul especially from
the construction sector and real estate
and that makes a huge difference in
terms of Distributing to the population
and in terms of maintaining the populist
populist policies that our party has
relied on Istanbul constitutes 20
percent of turkey's population on May 14
estimated 64 million Turkish citizens
will cast their ballots nearly 12
million are in Istanbul Istanbul is
micro Cosmos of turkey
although it is different
groups social groups are represented in
Istanbul in 1950s Istanbul was described
as a city paved with gold because it
provided millions of job opportunities
more recently It produced reject a
person who served as a stumble mayor
before he went on to become Prime
Minister and then president now current
mayor ekram imamolu is expected to
become vice president if the opposition
wins the opposition's victory in the
Istanbul mayoral elections four years
ago shattered erdon's Aura of
invincibility and struck the first
warning Bell for the upcoming vote
that's why during his Grand Istanbul
rally early in May erdogan said if
Istanbul says okay we will win for sure
hoping to secure the nest that he moved
on from decades ago see Namco solo Al
Jazeera Istanbul